بمجرد وصولنا إلى طرابلس ، كانت في
الأساس لعبة انتظار ، علمنا أن
هناك عددًا من هذه المزادات
تجري في مجموعة متنوعة من
المواقع المختلفة وعرفنا أنها تحدث
مرة أو مرتين في الشهر ، أعتقد أنها
ربما تكون أطول أيام قليلة بين
أطول أيام قليلة في حياتي في انتظار
سماع ما إذا كان هذا يحدث بالفعل ،
احتجنا إلى الدفع لمحاولة الوصول
إلى هؤلاء الأشخاص ، هناك واحد إلى اثنين من
هذه المزادات كل شهر وأن
هناك مزادًا يحدث في الساعات القليلة القادمة
لذلك نحن  لن أعرف بصدق
ما كنت أتوقع الدخول فيه ، أعتقد أنني
لم أستطع معرفة كيف يمكنك
عقليًا بيع
البشر الآخرين ، ثم عندما
سمعتهم عندما سمعناهم يتحدثون عن هؤلاء
الأشخاص الذين كانوا يبيعونهم
كسلعة ، كان الأمر منطقيًا لأنك
بحاجة إلى درجة معينة من التنافر المعرفي ،
يجب أن تكون إنسانيًا
، لقد حان الوقت لتنتقل ، لا يزال
لديك وظيفة للقيام بذلك ، مما يصرف انتباهك قليلاً
عما أنت للتو  شهدنا ولكن عندما كنا
نجلس هناك بالفعل نشاهد
المزاد ، شعرت أن كل شيء كان
يسير بحركة بطيئة للغاية ،
كانت هناك كل الأشياء التي كنا نعلم أننا
بحاجة إلى ضربها حيث جعله الصحفيون
يستخدم كلمة المزاد على الصوت الخاص بنا
لتأكيد ذلك  مزاد علني يجعل
البائع يؤكد بيع
12 شخصًا في تلك الليلة مع كل
ذلك كدليل
أتذكر أنني كنت بالخارج في موقف السيارات
بمركز الاحتجاز ودرت
حول الزاوية وكانت هناك هذه
الغرفة الضخمة وكانت الجبهة  منفتح على
العناصر وكان ظاهريًا كان قفصًا
صحيحًا كان قفصًا سلكيًا وكان الناس
ينظرون إليك من الجانب الآخر وأتذكر أنني
كنت أفكر أنك تعرف ما إذا كانت
غوريلا واحدة هناك
يعتقد الناس كم هو حزين لم يكن لديه  الكثير من
الغرف ثم اتضح أنه كان هناك
أكثر من ألف شخص هناك كل
يوم في بيئة كهذه يعد
عدم القدرة على الاستحمام جيدًا
والجلوس هناك دون الحصول على الطعام الذي
تحتاجه  الشعور بالعطش ، لذلك كل ساعة مهمة
تركهم وراءهم في مكان مغلق من
هذا القبيل وعدم القدرة على المساعدة
لأنه لا يمكنك مساعدة أحدهم ،
عليك أن تساعد الآلاف في ذلك
لأنه لا يمكنك الذهاب إلى عدد قليل
الناس وأكون مثل كيف يمكنني مساعدتك ، فأنت
تحتاج حقًا إلى مساعدتهم جميعًا ،
كانت هناك نقطة حيث كنت أنا وأليكس نجري
مقابلة مع النصر البالغ من العمر 21 عامًا
والذي تم استعباده وكنت
غارقة لأن النصر كان
غارقًا ،
فأنت تعلم أن حلمه كان  أن يكون مصممًا
أراد القدوم إلى إيطاليا
والعمل كمصمم أزياء وربما يعمل يومًا ما
مع Dolce & Gabbana وكان هذا
حلمًا مرتبطًا به ولماذا لا
لأنه يحاول ليس بالضبط أعتقد أن هذه هي
القصة الأولى في  منذ وقت طويل حيث كنت أعاني من
الكوابيس ، كان هناك شيء
مفجع حقًا حول
أحلام الناس التي يتم استغلالها
بهذه الطريقة ، أعتقد أننا جميعًا كنا نفكر في
أنك تعلم أننا نأمل فقط أن نتمكن من
تحقيق العدالة لهذا الأمر